our subject for this afternoon
the silence of the lamb the silence of
the lamb
out of the depth have i cried unto thee
o lord
lord hear my voice and let thine ears be
attentive to the voice of my
supplications
if thou lord shouldst mark iniquities
oh lord who shall stand but there is
forgiveness with thee that thou mayest
be feared
i wait for the lord my soul doth wait
and in his word do i hope my soul
waiteth for the lord
more than they that watch for the
morning i say
morning let
israel hope in the lord for with the
lord this mercy
and with him is plenteous redemption and
he shall redeem israel
from all his iniquities
thank god again from the foundation of
my soul for this tremendous honor
of speaking for him angels would love
to speak for god and talk about jesus
but that honor is reserved for sinners
such as i
and so i really really thank god that he
will allow me
to be an ambassador for him an
ambassador of truth
and my pledge to my god is that i will
try to deliver
thus saith the lord and as i often say
keep my opinions to myself because they
really
have no saving value whatsoever but the
words of god
jesus says of the words the words that i
speak unto you
they are spirit and they are life
and that is what i desire to give you
this afternoon
i welcome you wherever you are thank you
very much facebook youtube whatever zoom
thank you so much and may the lord bless
you individually
ellen white tells us the relations
between god and each soul
are as distinct and full as though there
were not
another soul upon the earth to claim his
watch care
not another soul for whom he gave his
beloved son
god deals with us very very personally
and i'm asking god to bless every
listener
personally by just one single message
for those of you who are not seventh-day
adventists
thank you very much for joining us we
are delighted and honored with your
presence
and again may the lord touch you in a
way that is consistent with his will
for your lives and may he doubly bless
your children
for anyone who may have contracted the
coronavirus
i am praying for you and will continue
to pray for you
and i want you to know that the god who
sits in heaven is the god who calls
himself
the god that heals and of course
jesus did more healing and miraculous
work than he did
preaching so i'll ask god to be merciful
to you and to remove that dreadful
affliction
which has taken over 300 000 lives
in the united states alone our subject
for this afternoon
the silence of the lamb the silence of
the lamb
let me remind you politely at five
o'clock we will try to answer your
questions
send them in and as you think of
questions don't think only of yourself
think perhaps will this question if it
is answered bless
many people or will it simply satisfy
personal
bible curiosity i cannot tell you what
question to us
but consider others will the answering
of this question
have a wide effect on people or is this
just to satisfy
my personal curiosity it's up to you but
i thought i would give you that
guideline
as you formulate your questions
of course we meet again tomorrow but
we'll tell you about that more
a little later before i get into the
message i ask you as i always do please
preserve reverence where you are because
we are worshiping the god of heaven and
earth
and part of that reference may be to
make sure that these things are turned
off
but since we're in the age of
electronics and
technology and connectedness you may
need to use these to connect with this
program
and we understand if not make sure it
does not cause a distraction
favor number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say lord
put your words in that man's mouth
please do that
jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9 then the lord
put forth his hand
and touched my mouth and the lord said
unto me behold i
have put my words in thy mouth ask
god to put his words in my mouth and he
will do that there is a verse in ii
samuel chapter 23 verse 2
which i love very much it says this the
spirit of the lord spake by me
and his word was in my tongue the very
instrument of speech and i want god to
do that for me
and of course favor number three i want
you to think very rigorously
as you listen isaiah 118 come now
let us reason together saith the lord
so think reason as the word of god
is delivered let's bow our heads now and
pray
father in heaven i always thank you for
life
because i really thank you thank you
father for the freedom we have to
worship you
thank you lord for this weekend revival
program watch
pray and work if i have offended you
forgive me i ask of you in the name of
jesus
who shed his blood that i might be
cleansed by that blood at my request
father grant to us your spirit he is the
spirit of truth
jesus said in john 16 13 how be it
when he the spirit of truth is come he
will guide you into all truth
grant to me and to those listening that
spirit of truth dear god
that our minds might be led a right
because without your spirit
with all our education we will guide
ourselves into error
father bless our visitors in a very
special way bless the children who are
watching in a very very
special way to god and for anyone who
may have contracted the coronavirus
i ask you as an act of mercy and you are
a merciful god
micah 7 18 describes you as one who
delighteth in mercy
may it delight you their god to heal
anyone under the sound of my voice who
have been infected by this coronavirus
heal that person
heal those persons rebuke that dreadful
condition they got
at the sound of your word because the
word it creates
is the word that heals hear this humble
prayer father
may this message glorify your name and
bless your people
i offer it from my heart in jesus name
amen our subject
the silence of the lamb
in our earlier presentation this morning
the impotence of omnipotence we
learn some things about jesus christ
now we will follow the same procedure we
will learn a few things about
god let us go to
john chapter 1 again john 1.
john chapter 1 we read from verse 1
and let me recommend the gospel of john
again
and he gives a very specific reason why
he wrote that gospel
but i won't tell you now because
curiosity will drive you to read it
and i don't want you distracted but i'll
tell you later he gives a precise
reason why he wrote his gospel and your
heart will rejoice when you read that
reason
john 1 reading from verse 1 i read from
the king james version of the bible
in the beginning was the word and the
word was with god
and the word was god the same was in the
beginning
with god all things were made by him and
without him
was not anything made that was made
in him was life and the life was the
light
of men meaning all people in
him was life and the life was the light
of men
and the light shineth in darkness and
the darkness comprehended it not
there was a man sent from god whose name
was john
the same came for a witness to bear
witness of the light that
all men through him might believe so
we've discovered two things
in him was life and the life was the
light of
men and that verse 9 says that was the
true light
which lighteth every man that cometh
into the world
jesus christ touches everyone who comes
into this world
somehow he touches them
without christ you cannot be born
because the processes that
lead to birth are all directed by the
word of god
every single person who comes into this
world
is somehow touched by the power of
christ
and so this informs us that christ has
an
interest in every single person
let us go to first timothy chapter two
let's read verse four first timothy
chapter two
reading verse four we're discovering
something about
jesus about god the father's will
first timothy chapter 2 verse 4 says who
will have
all men to be saved and to come
unto the knowledge of the truth
god will have all people
saved that is his desire of course not
all of god's desires are fulfilled
because there is something called human
cooperation
no one is saved by force
we are saved by invitation but he will
have
all men all people to be saved
and to come unto the knowledge of the
truth so if you're a bible worker
and you're trying to teach people the
word you are working in cooperation with
the will of god
because the verse says he will have all
people
come to the knowledge of the truth
let us go to ii peter chapter three
let's read verse nine
ii peter chapter three reading verse
nine
we're learning something about god about
christ our subject
the silence of the lamb
the lord is not slack concerning his
promises as some men come slackness
but is long suffering to us word not
willing that any should perish but that
all
should come to repentance
the lord is not willing that any should
perish
but that all should come to repentance
god
wants to save every single person
who has ever been born of adam
this is his desire and that has not
changed now
if this is the case
why is it that most people
will be lost
it's a universal tragedy that a god
who would love to save everyone
will end up watching most people lost
let me tell you something about god's
desire to save everyone
in the parable of the sheep and the
goats
in verse 34 of matthew 25 the bible says
then shall the king say unto them on his
right hand
come ye blessed of my father inherit the
kingdom prepared for you
from the foundation of the world now
keep these words in mind
concentrate listen microscopically
inherit
the kingdom prepared for you
from the foundation of the world it has
always been god's desire to save
everyone
notice what he says to those who are
lost
depart from me verse 40 42 verse 40 41
depart for me cursed into everlasting
fire
prepared for the devil and his angel
god prepared hell for the devil
and his angels yet
i almost said we there will be many
human beings
in hell with the devil and his angels
not invited they will all be gate
crashers
you're going somewhere not prepared for
you
and i'm expressing the mercy of god let
me say it again
every lost person will end up in a place
god did not prepare for him or for her
what did god prepare
his kingdom
there is a god in heaven who has room in
his heart
and in his house for every person born
since adam but most of those vacancies
will go unfilled because people choose
otherwise
let me pray again and i move to the next
point father
restrain me instruct me use me
in jesus name amen let us go
to luke 23.
luke 23 we've just discovered that god
would love to save
everyone and this is most beautifully
expressed in john 3 16
for god so loved the world he gave
christ
for the world all right we're now in
luke 23 reading from verse
39 of luke 23
and one of the male factors which were
hanged railed on him saying
if thou be christ save thyself and us
but the answer answering the other
answering rebuked him saying
doth not thou fear god seeing thou art
in the same condemnation
and we indeed justly for we receive the
jew reward of our deeds
but this man hath done nothing or miss
and he said unto jesus lord
remember me when thou comest into thy
kingdom and jesus said unto him in verse
verily i say unto thee today i am
telling you right now
thou shalt be with me in paradise
all right matthew 27
38 says then were two thieves crucified
with him
one of the right hand and another on the
left
matthew 27 38 luke 23
39 tells us and the male factors
mali means bad factors to do bad doers
the sinners the criminals the convicts
the malefactors one of them
but go with me to matthew 27 let's read
verse 44
our subject the silence of the lamb the
lamb of course being the one who was
dying on the cross
jesus christ matthew 27
reading verse 44.
well let's go to 38 and read from 38 get
some connection
then were they two thieves crucified
with him
one on the right hand and another on the
left and there that passed by
reviled him wagging the heads and saying
thou that destroys the temple
and builds it in three days save thyself
if thou be the son of god
come down from the cross and so we have
those passing by
the passes by because crucifixions were
public events
and they made fun of christ likewise
also the chief priests mocking him
with the scribes and elders said he
saved
others himself he cannot save if he be
the king of israel
let him now come down from the cross and
we will believe him verse 43
he trusted in god let him deliver him
now if he will have him
because he said i for he said i am the
son of god
so the chief priests the elders the
scribes the pastors by
those not mentioned the soldiers they
all made fun
of jesus now listen to verse 44
of matthew 27 what does that say the
thieves
also which were with him cast the same
in his teeth there was in other words
they too were making fun of christ
but i want you to observe the verse says
the thieves
which means that at some point
that thief who eventually got saved
was making fun of jesus
something happened to him on that cross
as he looked at christ
as he looked at the man whom he was
humiliating
and cursing something
happened to him and he recognized
in christ the savior with that
background
let us go back to luke 23 we'll pick it
up again from verse 39
our subject the silence of the lamb
and one of the male factors which were
hanged reeled on him saying
if thou be christ save thyself and us
one of them railed on him
in matthew 27 44 both 44
both of them were doing it but one has
changed
but the other answering rebuked him now
pause
here's a lesson for us when someone
is truly converted the person
makes a 180 degree turn
are you with me there's a song i like
very much
the things i used to do i do them no
more
the things i used to eat i eat them no
the clothes i used to wear i wear them
no more
the friends i used to have i have them
this thief now goes from matthew 27 44
joining his friend in humiliating christ
now he's rebuking the frame
because something has happened in his
heart in that
instant on the cross now he's a
different man
but the other answering rebuked him
saying does not thou fear god
seeing thou art in the same condemnation
and we
indeed justly is almost preaching the
gospel
we deserve what we're getting which is
absolutely true
for we receive the due rewards of our
deeds
we have been criminals we are justly on
this cross
but this man hath done nothing or miss
he calls him a man in verse 42 he calls
him lord
so he sees man human that humanity he
sees god divinity
tremendous revelation by the spirit to
that thief on the cross
and jesus said unto him verse 43 verily
i say unto thee today
thou shalt be with me in paradise
let's reflect there were two thieves on
that
on those crosses there were three
criminals on the hill
i said three criminals in the eyes of
the law and christ was one
he was numbered with the transgressions
are you with me
he was viewed as a criminal the father
treated him as a sinner as a sinner
he was cursed christ redeemed us from
the curse of the law
being made accursed for us who made him
a curse the father had to pour out his
wrath and allow
all the powers of darkness to do what
they would do with jesus christ he died
as a sinner
a criminal an offender as but never
having sinned
he was dying for both thieves
let me say that slowly jesus christ
was dying for both thieves
plus the world he only saved
one of the two
he spoke to the one on the right
and i use the word right because the
right in the bible is the side of power
the side of victory he spoke to the one
on the right
and guaranteed him a place in his
kingdom
but he was silent to the one on the left
he said nothing to him but he was dying
for both
the silence of the lamb
silent to one talking
to the other why was that
one responded the other
did not
let me say that again one did what is
required of the sinner
in cooperation with god for salvation to
take place
you cannot save yourself i
cannot save myself but something is
required of
me in order that god might save me
i cannot save myself i cannot fix my
cavity
but something is required of me in order
for my dentist to fix my cavity
review and herald october 30 1888
paragraph three the review on herald
october 30 1888 paragraph three
in the work of redemption
god requires the cooperation of man
the christian must put forth strenuous
exertions
and god will unite divine grace with his
human effort
let me say that again the review and
herald
october 30 1888 paragraph three
in the work of redemption
god requires the cooperation of male
people the christian must put forth
strenuous exertions strenuous exertions
and god will come unite divine
grace with his human effort
it is not your effort that saves you it
is your effort that
lets god see you want to be saved
in that same uh
page reverend herald october 13 88 now
paragraph
four that man has
only to believe and nothing else
is a fallacy and a
dangerous doctrine that man has
only to believe is a fallacy and the
most
dangerous doctrine and yet the bible
does not support salvation by works
but surely god requires of us
something we must do in order that he
might save us
now listen to this clinching quotation
from our beloved
servant of the lord reverend herald
october 30 1888 paragraph eight
those who take the position that christ
has done it all
and that we need not obey god's
requirements
will fail of everlasting life they will
fail of everlasting life those who take
the position
that christ has done it all and that we
need not obey the requirements of god
will fail i was asked to give a morning
devotion to a group of workers somewhere
on the face of the earth
one identified and i was talking about
the need to cooperate with god
this man pumped his fist
i thank god jesus did it all i have
nothing to do
and i wanted to hit him with the bible
but
you know he can't practice violence in
the pulpit or anywhere else
but i was really upset with that man he
pumped his face
i thank god jesus did it all have
nothing to it
no he didn't do it all he did all he had
to do
there's something you and i must do
the bible is full of those examples of
the fact that there's something required
of us
matthew 11 28 come unto me
all you that labor and are heavy laden i
will give you but the condition
is come
we're all familiar with revelation 3 20
behold i stand at the door and
knock if any man hear my voice and
open the door i will come into him and
will sup with him and he with me
there must be a response to the grace of
god
because no one is saved contrary to his
will
and no one is lost contrary to his will
or her will
hell is entered by choice
heaven is entered by a choice that god
honors
we need no help from god to go to hell
we need god help from god to go to
heaven are you following me
we don't even need help from the devil
to go to hell because if satan died
tonight we will sin tonight
you don't sin because there's a devil we
sin because we choose a sin
temptations do not mean you have to sin
temptations are invitations to which we
can say yes
or no
there's a part that you and i
must play those who
take the position that
christ has done it all
and that we need not obey the
requirements of god
will fail of everlasting life
there will be people entering hell with
the look of shock and surprise on their
faces
because they thought that jesus did
everything
and nothing was required of them
go to first john chapter 3 let's read
verse 23.
first john 3 23 our subject the silence
of the lamb first john 3 20 i'll pray as
you're looking forth in heaven continue
to speak through me on this very very
serious issue i pray give me simple
language i ask
in jesus name amen first john 3 verse 23
and this is his what commandment stop
this is his commandment
so we're commanded to do what this is
his commandment that we should do what
believe on whom
the name of his son jesus christ
this we are commanded to believe in
jesus
now we're free to disobey now john 3 16
says
for god so loved the world that he gave
his only begotten son
that whosoever believeth
now i want to put your intellect to the
test i believe you'll pass
don't disappoint my faith look at first
john 3 23
and look at john 3 16 and tell me a
different
way to say john 3 16 which is still
correct first john 3 23 says this
is his commandment that we should
believe in the name of the lord of his
son jesus christ and love one another
as he gave us commandment this is his
commandment we should believe on his son
jesus christ
now john 3 16 says whosoever believeth
should not perish but have everlasting
life if god
commands you to believe
and you believe what have you done
listen to me carefully it's easy
if god tells you believe
and you believe what have you done you
have
obeyed
the condition of salvation is obedience
that is not salvation by works the
moment you preach salvation by works you
have to knock down the cross of calvary
calvary's cross stands as an argument
against salvation by works
but salvation requires something of us
when we obey god first john 3 23
he commands us to believe when we
believe we have obeyed now if you read
john 3 16
for god so loved the world that he gave
his only begotten son
that whosoever obeyeth
should not perish but have everlasting
life
whosoever obeys
because we are commanded to obey
the condition of salvation
is obedience not just believe believe
believe
believe believe believe by itself is an
act of death
because faith is dead being alone
in the book faith and works page 101
paragraph one writing to eighty jones a
form of rebuke
because he was preaching somewhere and
stressing just believe just believe just
believe
to an extreme degree to the point that
it might led people to believe might
have led him to believe i have nothing
to do
ellen white writes there are conditions
to our receiving
justification and righteousness and
sanctification
and the righteousness of christ she said
i know your meaning
but you leave a wrong impression upon
many minds
while good works will not save even one
soul
not even one soul can be saved without
good works that's what she writes now
listen to what she said
god saves us under a law
that we must ask if we will receive
seek if we will find knock
if we would have the door open unto us
the intriguing statement she makes is
god saves us
under a law he doesn't say he saves us
by a law
he saves us under a law here is the law
here is the condition you've got to ask
you've got to seek
you've got to in other words you have to
have a response
it's not just believe believe believe
and that is it belief
must be accompanied by something we do
that's called works
and works in this context is not that
which saves us
it is that which expresses our faith in
the saving power of jesus christ
i give you that quotation again
reviewing herald october 30
1888 paragraph eight those who take
the position that christ has done it all
and that we need not obey the
requirements of god
will fail of everlasting life
one of the most well-known verses in the
bible is first john chapter 1 verse 9.
and you can tell me what it says if we
confess our sins when you see the word
if what is introduced
a condition a condition
and you find if all the way through
first john chapter one by the way a very
interesting chapter
if we say if this if this if that
if we confess our sins if we do this
he is faithful and just to forgive us
our sins
and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness in other words there is
a connection between
the fulfillment of a condition and the
carrying out
of god's part of the arrangement if we
confess
god forgives but god is so good
he helps us to do our part
because confession is a result of the
spirit of god working on the heart you
see
we can't help god do his he helps us do
ours
this is grace
if we confess the goodness of god
leadeth thee to come to
repentance and to confession with you
see there is no
need for confession in the not no need
there is no
desire in the flesh to confess
the flesh does not confess
the flesh does not repent let me ask you
this question
is confession a good thing yes or no yes
is repentance a good thing yes or no it
is god that puts it in you to repent
it must be good but paul says i know
that in me that is in my flesh
dwelleth no good thing
then repentance cannot come from the
flesh
confession cannot come from the flesh
sorrow for sin
cannot come from the flesh god in his
mercy in his love
in his tireless expression of grace he
puts these urges and
impulses within us and hopes that we
will
express them there is a work
for us to do and i use the word work
very carefully i do not want to give the
impression of salvation by words
there is no such thing if there were
salvation by works there would have been
no need for christ to die
let me repeat the cross of christ is a
standing argument
against the error of salvation by works
but there is something we must do
when god told abraham let me pray again
father
help me to tell this account very
clearly to your glory please in jesus
name
amen in genesis 22
god told abraham to sacrifice
isaac on a mountain in moriah which i
will tell thee of
verse four abraham rose up early in the
morning sadly his ass
took to his young and with him isaac his
son claimed the wood for the burnt
offering
and rose up and went into the place
which god had told him of
on the third day abraham lifted up his
eyes and saw the place afar off and
abraham took the wood put it on isaac
took the fire the knife he did all these
things verse 9
and they came to the place which god had
told him of and abraham built an altar
there and laid the wood in order upon
the altar he did all this thing
when you lifted the knife god said now
i know now fear is me
now now god knows everything don't
misunderstand me but he's talking in a
way we can understand
god said i saw you rise early i saw you
have prepared the donkeys
i saw you get your servants i saw you
wick isaac carefully so sarah would not
know
i saw you traveling i saw you prepare
the altar
i saw you prepare the wood i saw you
place the wood in order
god must be worshiped in order
i saw you place the word in order i saw
you bind your son
i saw you stretch him on the altar i saw
your tears coming from your eyes and i
saw you lift that knife
as your aged hand shook and i saw you
about to kill him
now i know now
many of us as christians god is still
waiting to say now i know
because we show god nothing
we show him nothing and the bible
talks about the sacrifices isaac as
though it actually happened
because it happened here are you with me
it happened abraham was 100
committed to sacrifice his son that was
enough for god
the physical expression was no longer
necessary
abraham showed god and so hebrews 11 17
says by faith
abraham when he was tried offered up
isaac
and he that had received the promises
offered up his only begotten son
abraham in god's eyes offered up isaac
and god said now i know
god says now i know based on not on what
he does but
based on our response to him abraham
is the symbol of faith because
of his works let me say that again i'll
pause first so you think
job is the symbol of what
patience abraham is the symbol of faith
that's why paul uses him in romans and
galatians
in his argument about righteousness by
faith he goes to abraham doesn't go to
enoch or
methuselah or whomever he goes to
abraham
abraham's faith was established by his
works
let me ask you this as i continue the
silence of the lamb
as i try to show you there's something
you must do
what you do does not save you what you
do let god see you respect him
you honor the conditions he's laid out
abraham came to the place where he could
not have children genesis 17 verse 17
he laughed at god then abraham fell on
his face and laughed and said in his
heart
shall a child be born unto him that is
100 years old and shall sarah that is 90
years old there
abraham laughed at the thought that he
had a hundred and sarah at night he
could have a child
romans 4 19 says his loins were dead and
sarah's woman was dead
that's what the bible says
but they had a son
abraham had a son of faith
ishmael was the son of works are you
following me
isaac was the son of faith but let me
ask you this
ishmael was the son of faith because
abraham was still able physically
to father a child with hagar
abraham and hagar had to come together
physically to have this child you know
what i'm talking about
that's the child who works but they also
had to come together physically
to produce isaac but he's the son of
faith what happened
they were responding in faith to the
word of god
a man with dead loins and a woman with
the dead womb
responding to god's word of faith came
together
and from a dead loin and a dead womb
came a living boy can you say amen
that is god honoring our works
or our faith demonstrated by works
abraham could have stayed in his stand
and sarah in another tent and tried this
thing by jumper cables it would not have
worked
they had to come together
that's works expressing faith
god wants to bless you financially he
really does
because poverty widespread poverty in
the church does not glorify god
then who wants to join this god where
everyone is poor
widespread sickness does not glorify god
why join a church where everyone is sick
and broken down
where is the power of god widespread
divorce does not glorify god
where is the power of god god is
glorified in a healthy people a
prosperous people
are tightly knit people
but health is based on conditions
financial prosperity has conditions now
there's a worldly way to prosper
but that prosperity ends when christ
comes the biblical
form of prosperity extends into the
world to come
when jesus said lay it up for yourselves
treasures on earth wear moth and rust
does corrupt
and we thieves break through and steal
but lay up for yourselves treasures in
heaven
that was not symbolic language
in the new world different people have
different degrees of possession and
whatever else
in the new world it was god's
arrangement before sin
let me say it again it was god's
arrangement before
sin that people would have wealth
somewhere i read eloise says the desire
to accumulate wealth
is an original impulse of our nature
planted there by god
for noble ends for good purposes let me
say it again
the the the desire to accumulate wealth
is an original impulse placed in us by
god
but for noble ends i'll find that
quotation give you this afternoon
what am i trying to say in the silence
of the lamb we have
something to do i must confess
and god will forgive come unto me
i'll give you rest now coming to god is
a very short distance because christ is
already at your door you understand
you don't have to travel far he makes it
easy to come
because he's come all the way to the
door of your heart he's standing on the
welcome mat but out of respect he does
not walk in
you must invite him you must desire
jesus christ
because christ is preparing you for a
kingdom where there will be no more sin
and that kingdom will be populated by
people who have made a choice that will
last forever
we want righteousness not sin
i must invite him in i must confess
i must return the tithe
our works bring blessings our works
bring curses
you can't escape works go to titus
chapter 1
something interesting titus 1 let's read
verse 16.
our subject the silence of the lamb
we saw that christ said nothing to one
thief he saved another he was silent to
one he spoke to another why
one responded one didn't titus chapter 1
verse 16 let's read that verse
carefully microscopically
do you have it they profess
that they know god but in works
they deny him being abominable
and disobedient those are the works you
see abominable and disobedient
and unto every good work reprobate now
we have listen to the verse again
they profess that they know god but in
works
they deny him being abominable
and disobedient disobedience
expresses hatred for god to some degree
and unto every good work reprobate so we
have
evil works in that verse and we have
good works
now if the evil works being reprobate
disobedient
deny god what do the good works do
as verily as evil works deny
god the good works
establish i hope that's the good word
demonstrate
that we truly believe in a righteous god
we have good works
evil words that verses so they profess
you know what jesus said this people
honoreth me with their
lips they profess but their hearts
are far from me
they profess that they know god
but in works they deny him
being abominable and disobedient
and unto every good work so the good
work at the end of that verse
is not the same as their works deny him
no we have two
different quality of works in that verse
the works that deny him
and the good works that the sinners
don't like my brothers and sisters
your life is either an expression of
good works that honor god
or evil works that deny god you cannot
escape
works your works don't save you but your
works show you want to be saved
your works show that you love god your
work shows that you prefer righteousness
my work sure i want a place in god's
kingdom and i often like
i often say that god is from missouri
show me and if you're from
outside united states you may not
understand but god is from missouri
god says show me
listen to john 3 16 when god tells you
show me
he's asking you to behave like him for
god so loved the world
that he showed us
are you with me he showed us how he gave
his only begotten son
god loves to demonstrate love is love
only in demonstration
ah you missed it my fault i used too
many big words like love and
demonstration
let me find some smaller words
love that is not expressed is not love
is that clear enough
without demonstration there is no love
the same way there's no faith where
there's no work there's no love with
there's no expression
i love you as in love i'm dying for you
that's love
i love you is in love you call me i'm
broken down i'm in the ditch it's 10
degrees below come help me
i come that's love not i'll pray for you
the silence of the lamb let's review
jesus died between two thieves in the
eyes of those who carried out the
crucifixion there were three criminals
he was dying for both
so sad he only saved one
not because he could not save the other
the other did not seek salvation
he spoke to one he was silent
to the other
the silence of the lamb question for you
is god silent in your life
make sure you serve a god who loves to
talk
respond to him this weekend revival
might have been arranged by god to reach
one person whether in person
or via the internet let me say it again
god loves everyone god
wants to save that's his desire to save
everyone second peter chapter three
verse nine first timothy chapter two
verse four
but god ultimately will not be able to
do that
because we must come to him jesus
complained to the scribes and pharisees
in john 5 40 he will not come to me
that he might have life you just won't
come
your mother has begged you to come to
church your parents have begged you to
study the bible
they pray you will not do it now you're
in court before
judge who's about to send you up for 10
years for whatever you did with your
friends
we must respond to god and i'm asking
you today as i close
make a response to god and the only
response god wants
is the total surrender of the life to
him
here's how it is described in the bible
let me pray before i do that father
as i close be with me again please i
pray in the name of jesus
amen mark 12 reading from verse 28 go
there with me
mark 12 reading from verse 28.
the second gospel the shortest gospel
mark 12 reading from verse 28 the bible
says
and one of the scribes came and having
heard them
reasoning together and perceiving that
he answered them well asked him which is
the first commandment of all
and jesus answered him the first of all
the commandment is hear o israel the
lord our god is one lord
and thou shalt love the lord thy god
with all thy heart with all thy soul
with all thy mind
with all thy strength what does that
mean
he repeats the word all all all
all and we have
understanding i think verse 33 all the
understanding
and in deuteronomy 6 we have all your
might so we have
soul spirit all your heart with all your
soul all your might all your strength
all your understanding
the surrender to god must be complete
or god cannot save you let me say it
again
the surrender to god must
be complete we are a people of
statistics
we make national policies based on
statistics and studies
statisticians round off the numbers nine
point seven is ten
statistically eight point eight is nine
and seven point two
is seven with god seven point two is 7.2
god does not round off figures he gave
10 commandments
9 out of 10 qualifies you for hell
ah you missed it 9 out of 10
qualifies you for hell but at the
university of uh fairview valley
you you get a degree with honors nine
out of ten that's honors
in god's system it's all
or nothing
god is not a statistician
he requires entire surrender
faith and works page 100 paragraph one
ella white writes
god requires the entire surrender of the
heart
in order for justification to take place
let me ask you this as we view this
arithmetically mathematically
numerically
here's 100 percent let's say i surrender
to god
99 that will cause the world to share
who controls the one percent
satan that can't work it cannot work
because that one percent is all the
devil needs
to draw me to him and to ruin my life as
much as the kingdom of god
is like a grain of mustard seed the
kingdom of satan
is like a grain of mustard seed if it is
not
dealt with it will destroy the life
many of us are partially surrendered and
it makes us decent
law abiding but decent and law abiding
in the eyes of the law is not enough the
surrender
must be complete my listening friend
and it must be daily
and it is i who have to surrender it is
you
who must surrender those who take the
position
that christ has done it all and that we
need not obey the requirements of god
will fail of everlasting life review and
herald
october 30 1888 paragraph eight
do not allow the lamb to be silent in
your life
many times our prayers are not answered
because we do not
fulfill the conditions
and so god is quiet because god does not
function
contrary to his divine principles he
tries to bring up
us up to the place where we cooperate no
ellen white writes
never bring the gospel down to a low
level in order to gather converts
but seek to bring the sinful and
corrupted up to the high standard of the
law of god
and god tries to bring us up to his
standard he never comes down to ours
and when we fulfill conditions we are
coming up
to god's standards and god's standards
have no drawbacks
god's standards have no demerits they're
all designed for our blessing
and a glorious life do not allow
the lamb to be silent in your life
remember
the jesus who died for both thieves only
saved one
not because he did not want to save the
other but no one can be saved against
his
will the other did not respond and he
will be lost
as verily as the one on the right will
be saved
be the one on the right
reach out to god because he has first
reached out to you in the humanity of
jesus christ
he has reached out to you he understands
what is happening in your life
and as god he can do something about it
let me say that again
as man he understands whether you're 14
or 19 or
30. he understands he has gone through
those phases
and as god he can do something about it
we have friends who understand but can
do nothing jesus is a friend
who understands and can do something but
he says to us
ye are my friends if he do whatsoever i
command you that's condition
john 15 14 ye are my friends
if he do whatsoever i command you
you cannot dodge obedience as the
fundamental condition for all the
blessings of god
how many of you with me right here will
say father help me by the grace and your
spirit's power
to fulfill the conditions you've set for
me can i see your hand do you mean that
ah see you in the lobby god bless you
let's pray father in heaven
the carnal nature hates anything that is
of god
we need a greater power to suppress it
that power is the spirit that brings the
life of christ
father enlighten our understanding
help us to understand their god
that salvation has conditions
there are conditions to our receiving
justification
sanctification and the righteousness of
christ
and that conditioned a god the condition
of conditions
is obedience even our believing in
christ
we're commanded to do first john 3 23
please god give us the heart of christ
a heart to obey you because obedience
actually is life disobedience
is death let not christ who died for the
world
go silent in our lives dear god
let us cooperate with our savior that he
may carry out the mission to which you
sent him
and that is to save everyone who will
allow him
father in heaven bind us to your bosom
through your
sunday god watch over us
a double blessing on our children heal
anyone who may have contracted the
coronavirus
a sweet blessing on all our visitors who
tuned in
now prepare us for a question and answer
session at five o'clock
give us wisdom to answer correctly bless
this government father
because all power comes from you you set
kings up
and you set them down so you guide the
thinking of those leading this country
and other countries
remind them their god that righteousness
exalteth the nation bless us
make us a blessing to others i pray in
jesus name
amen
[Music]
you